et notre invité ce soir c'est odile
marcellin france romain guélat vice
président de l'université des antilles
bonsoir il ya une semaine on l'a vu le
personnage de la guadeloupe
c'était lui mobilisés pour dénoncer la
répartition des moyens entre des pôles
universitaires de martinique et de
guadeloupe
donc la réponse aujourd'hui c'était une
réponse pour la guadeloupe la réponse
vous voulez dire votre mobilisation
aujourd'hui c'est une réponse à la
gouaille ans à faire de la baule où nous
ne répondons pas à une mobilisation de
la guadeloupe
nous souhaitons une université des
antilles qui fonctionne avec une équité
entre ces deux pôles et nous constatons
aujourd'hui que la gouvernance qui est
donc le président qui est garant de
l'équité pour déployer les moyens sur
les deux pôles de façon équilibrée et
bien ce cette équité n'est pas respectée
et la difficulté que nous avons
aujourd'hui que nous rencontrons c'est
une difficulté que nous rencontrons
depuis déjà maintenant deux ans c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de dialogue entre donc
la présidence de l'université un
véritable dialogue entre la présidence
de l'université et la vice présidence du
pôle universitaire et j'élargis en dix
ans le conseil d'administration du pôle
unis la situation dialogue politique ne
nous ait toujours refusé et on arrive à
une extrémité aujourd'hui où il ya une
décision qui est voulu de rapatrier 7
millions de masse à l'ajustement est ce
que tout ça c'est aussi ce n'est pas
peut-être aussi une question
d'interprétation parce que ce transfert
de 7 millions dont vous parlez l'instant
vers celle de fouillole est au contraire
perçu perçu j'ai dit bien par les
guadeloupéens par vos collègues
européens comme un rééquilibrage entre
les deux pôles alors monsieur je vous
dirais qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un
rééquilibrage les deux déséquilibrage
justement il y à une équité qui doit
être réalisée au niveau des deux poings
l'université a aujourd'hui nous avons un
pôle universitaire en martinique que
nous avons à développer il y a un projet
stratégique qui a qui doit être mis en
place pour définir nos objectifs en
matière de formation de recherche pour
le pôle ce projet est en cours de
finalisation
il ya un contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens qui doit être signé entre le
président de l'université et le pôle
universitaire avant même que
nous ayons pu définir les moyens dont
nous avons besoin puisque nous savons
déjà que les moyens qui sont sur le
point de martinique sont à peine
suffisant pour nous permettre de
réaliser de pérenniser notre offre de
formations et de développer aussi bien
la formation de la recherche qui nous
permettent de faire croît de répondre
aux besoins de notre territoire
et là c'est fondamental et je m'adresse
vraiment à la martinique
un pays sans université un pays est un
pays sans avenir
un pays qui ne peut pas former sa
jeunesse est un pays sans avenir et
c'est là le risque que nous avons et
nous sommes aujourd'hui épuisé le
conseil d'administration à sa majorité
était puisée de ce qu'il est en train de
se passer devant vous une personne
fatiguée épuisée parce qu en train de se
taire quand il quand il nous dit va nous
les journalistes quand ils vous
répondent que il ya plus d'étudiants en
guadeloupe qui est donc parfait par
conséquent il ya plus de professeurs à
payer est ce que vous entendez cet
argument ou pas il faut savoir que les
effectifs en martinique sont en hausse
permanente
ça c'est une première chose que je veux
clairement dire donc les parents nous
font toujours confiance
les étudiants nous font toujours
confiance des élèves le s'inscrire à
l'université des antilles en martinique
et nous avons début février nous allons
accueillir les élèves dans le cadre de
la journée d'orientation désilets et
d'intégration des élèves de terminale
pendant deux jours sur le campus de
schoelcher donc ça c'est une évidence
maintenant vous avez un projet
d'université qui est mis en place et
nous avons observé au cours des années
un double nage des formations en
guadeloupe à l'information entre doit en
lettres et sociales f1 en droit et
sciences économiques par une volonté
ford on avait politique au niveau de la
voix de lou et dans le même temps en
martinique
nous n'arrivons pas à développer les
formations sens expérimental la
recherche en sciences expérimentales qui
est absolument indispensable pour le
développement de notre territoire
l'économie bleus l'économie verte la
biodiversité
tous ces éléments fondamentaux pour
innover et pour créer de la valeur sur
notre série 3 si nous n'arrivons pas à
avoir les moyens à gardien
rien pour justement développer cela est
bien ne participons pas à au
développement d'un autre pays je pense
qu'on a bien entendu vos réponses donc à
la guadeloupe
la dernière question naturellement qu'on
se pose tous parce que l'on pense au
spectre de ce qui s'est passé avec la
guyane est ce qu'il ya à terme un risque
de divorce entre la martinique et la
guadeloupe c'est qu'elles sont pour moi
n'est pas d'actualité
ce qui est fondamental c'est que la loi
soit respectée que les statuts de
l'université soit respectée aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas le cas en permanence la loi
et les statuts sont violés que nous
ayons une université des antilles ou que
nous ayons une université de la
martinique là n'est pas la question
il faut en tous les cas que la loi soit
respectée et je vous dis très clairement
aujourd'hui que nous sommes à la
majorité sur sur le pôle martinique
nous sommes absolument défavorable à
l'idée de mettre en place une université
de la martinique nous voulons maintenir
pour nos territoires une université des
antilles attractif mais également que
l'autonomie des pôles universitaires
soient déployer leurs forces et
renforcées mises en place afin que nous
puissions répondre aux besoins de nos
territoires
merci madame face aux grains